well I I told you guys Oh a while back
months and months and months ago when it
was launched that Obamacare was
communism and I explained exactly why
and how it worked and how the economics
around that worked and how big a
disaster it was going to be I just got
some data in that will blow your mind
Obama to say that Obamacare is an
unmitigated economic disaster is an
understatement and here's what's sad
you're not going to hear this anywhere
else you're not even going to hear the
conservatives reporting on this for some
reason or another I guess they're too
busy worrying about Trump and Hillary
but I tried to explain to you how
insurance works and that when the cost
to cover someone a group of people goes
up that insurance companies have one
choice well two choices one go out of
business to raise their prices and that
Obama the people that put Obamacare
together either had one of two agendas
either they were absolute economic
morons which there's a real possibility
of that or they fully intended to
destroy the health insurance industry
and completely put them out of business
so that the government would be the only
provider of health insurance now I don't
know whether they are have that much
malice and that much of an intention
toward socialism or whether they're just
stupid I neither choice is good but
that's really your only two options let
me explain to you what's happening okay
we told you that because of Obamacare
that health insurance rates were going
to go through the roof didn't we didn't
we I told you that if you've been
listening to me I've told you this over
and over and over again well the first
piece of data I got was from my state
and my state's just in
negative of the other states and no
reason I got this data is because what
it's doing to our health insurance plan
Obamacare has cost my tiny low company
millions with an S of dollars already in
increased healthcare cost health
insurance cost now when a little company
like mine that has 600 team members is
cost millions of dollars that's if
there's a real simple effect to that
that's money I don't have to hire people
with because it's going to stupidity
it's real simple and so you want to slow
down job growth you know you suck money
out of the economy with a vacuum cleaner
called socialism on some kind of trash
like this now that's not just an opinion
it's an actual fact it's occurred with
my company has occurred with thousands
tens of thousands of companies just like
mine all over America but now get ready
it's not over
BlueCross BlueShield in the state of
tennessee is the largest insurer they
just pulled out of the exchange they
can't make the numbers work in the
exchange and they are announcing today a
62 percent increase in premiums for next
year 62 percent increase in premiums for
next year Oh
Cigna they had forecasted a 23% increase
they just came out today a 46% increase
in premiums Humana had forecasted that a
29% increase they came out today forty
four point three percent increase in
premiums if your blue jeans all went up
if a gallon of milk a gallon of gas all
went up sixty two and forty four percent
you people would be storming Washington
with pitchforks and torches
but you know what Americans are going to
stand back and look at this and yawn
because it's coming
they're companies and it's coming
through the group plans and they get the
bill and they're just like oh my god my
health insurance went up what am I going
to do I can't afford my health insurance
and it's all because of Obamacare it's
because socialism does not work it's a
very simple economic formula I mean
there's really this I mean a 6th grader
could walk you through this but these
morons and the White House can't figure
it out well let me tell you when you
when you take an industry and you
basically double the costs that it
charges to the consumer and the entire
industry does it so it's not like you
can go get a gallon of milk from
somebody else gallon of milk just
doubled gallon of gas just doubled the
cost to put tires on your car just
doubled you walk that you think Macy's
and JC Penney's would stay open if they
doubled all their prices what's that's
going to do to the economy 1/7 of the US
economy is health care 1/7 and it just
went up 62 and 44 percent and this state
is indicative of what's happening in
every other state it's not like
Tennessee's pregnant got a different
issue than everybody else this crap is
coming down from Washington DC and this
is the effect of Washington taking
control of an entire industry and
screwing it up and no I got to tell you
nobody's going to gripe about it you're
not going to hear anybody else fired up
about this like I am you're not going to
hear somebody it's not going to be the
promise you it's not the lead story on
the news tonight I'm a hundred percent
sure CBS NBC and ABC will give this zero
coverage zero and one seventh of our
economy just doubled and expense to your
back pocket and let me help you with
this if a company makes blue jeans or
milk and they have employees their costs
to do business just went up dramatically
do you think that that's not going to be
passed on to you and higher prices if
you don't think prices are going up
across the
on every product and service in America
as a result of this debacle
you're not smart Oh it'll be gradual and
it'll be incremental and that's how you
boil a frog you turn it up slowly and a
bunch of you frogs aren't paying enough
attention and you're getting boiled and
you're standing around going Obama is a
great president he's going to go down as
the worst president in the history of
the United States this is an
astronomical economic failure this is
absolute I've never seen anything like
this in my lifetime where an industry
just casually announces a 62 and a 44
and a 43% increase 46% increase in costs
and they're one of the largest
industries in the entire United States
big segment of our economy just changed
it's going to happen real quietly it's
not it's not a conspiracy it's just
people don't know what to get pissed off
about they're more worried about whether
Hillary's wearing diapers than this jeez
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a $500,000
income
you